Since we built out the model already,
we can go and
use the model comparison tool to
be able to analyse the quality
of the decision tree model
with an independent sample.
So what I'm going to do is go
over to my predictive section and
bring in that model comparison tool.
I'm going to load in the model
object from the decision tree
into this model comparison tool
into the M, or model input, and
the validation data set from the create
samples tool into the d or data side.
This option of the positive class in
a target variable, we do not need to
put in anymore since we're not trying to
predict a binary categorical variable,
but rather non-binary categorical data.
So there's no true positive class or
negative class here.
So instead, what I want to just
do is leave that blank, and
put in a browse tool
after this R output.
So let's maximize these results now,
and go interpret them.
So the decision tree had an accuracy
of the estimation sample up at 96%
which is quite high.
But now, what the model does not perform
quite as well with the validation sample
as the overall accuracy is much,
much lower at 84%.
This make me wonder if we
can build out a better model
that's a little more reliable.
This unreliability is often
seen in decision trees
due to their tendency to over fit
the model to their data sets.
The other model types we're going
to use is a force model and
boost models and they're both used
as an extension to decision trees,
but do just a good job at
combating this over-fitting issue.
Let's explore an exciting model
next called the forest model.